newly released surveillance video shows
a moment take a look at this closely
when a high school coach took a shotgun
away from a student at Parkrose high
school in Portland Oregon it was five
months ago his next move is even more
stunning after disarming him the coach
in the baseball cap gave the student a
hug a very long hug the community is
praising the coaches quick thinking and
compassion CBS this morning
lead national correspondent David Wagner
was with us with more on this story
David this this story could have ended
very very badly really powerful video
Gil good morning everyone by all
accounts the student was having a mental
health crisis the coach keen and low who
also works as a security guard on the
campus had been alerted that the student
had made suicidal statements so when the
student arrived coach Lowe realized it
was serious and potentially deadly in a
fraction of a second I analyzed
everything really fast I saw it the look
in his face look in his eyes looked at
the gun I realized it was a real gun and
then my instincts just took over those
instincts get the gun away from the
student fast but after Coach keen and
Lowe handed the gun off he did something
unexpected he put his arms around angel
granado's Diaz and just held him telling
him that it was going to be okay he
broke down and I just wanted to let him
know that I was there for him just
minutes earlier surveillance cameras
captured coach Lowe headed to the
classroom to get the 18 year old I walk
in there I get to the classroom I asked
the teachers is the student here he was
not but moments later he would be with a
loaded gun
the door opens and you know I'm within
arm's length of the doors there's a kid
with a gun a shotgun not lunch for the
gun put two hands on the gun and and he
had his two hands on the gun and
obviously the students are you know
running out of the classroom and
screaming police were called and the
campus was put on lockdown we all hid we
hid like under clothes and stuff - just
in case anything
what happened what did happen was that
Coach Lowe showed compassion for a young
man who would later tell police he
planned to complete suicide I told him I
was I was there to to save him I was
there for a reason this month granado's
Diaz pleaded guilty to gun possession
charges in a deal with prosecutors that
will spare him jail time a lot of times
especially when you're young you don't
realize what you're doing until until
it's over
it's a powerful moment there in a
statement from his attorney the young
man thanks coach Lowe for what he did
that day and says he wants to move
forward in his life in the best way
possible the suspect to his 19 years old
was sentenced to three years probation
and will receive mental health treatment
it is powerful you could see in the
beginning it's almost like he tried to
push the coach away but the coach
wouldn't let him go and then he returned
the hug and he kind of fell into his arm
extraordinary presence of mind from that
coach yeah
really all right David thank you